les stars du psg dans un jet privé paris
nantes ce week end 340 km un trajet
faisable en deux heures en tgv comme le
propose la sncf est ce une offre risible
apparemment oui hier en conférence de
presse qu'il ya la paix en pleurs de
rires
l'hiver sera rude c'est le titre de
cette vidéo de gazprom qui met en garde
l'europe une fois le gaz coupé par un
employé de la firme russe une vague de
froid défaire sur le vieux continent sur
fond d'une musique dramatique
la cible ne fait aucun doute drapeau de
l'union européenne images des capitales
berlin et paris
la chose la plus efficace c'est de
baisser un peu la clim quand il fait
chaud ce qui est plutôt le cas en ce
moment et c'est d'essayer de se caler
sur une référence de chauffage dès qu'il
commencera à faire fois à faire froid
pardon autour de 19 degrés dans la pièce
pour maintenir la température ambiante
si on fait c'est petit effort collectif
et petit effort collectif alors il sera
assez je dirais assez spontanément le
pays pourra atteindre ses objectifs de
sobriété dans ce clip d'une minute et 45
secondes on peut aussi voir des
éoliennes et des panneaux
photovoltaïques une façon de pointer les
insuffisances européenne en matière
d'énergie
là vous l'avez dit arnaud sumérienne
malraux a pris la parole hier sur
l'énergie oui il fallait un plan pour
l'énergie parce que sinon les français
cet hiver ils vont pas se chauffer un
fassi vont se chauffer mais pour
manifester donc il fallait réagir alors
emmanuel macron a aussi proposé qu'on
envoie du gaz à l'allemagne ils ont fait
n'importe quoi avec le leur en 43
octobre maintenant il en manque et bah
c'est le karma voilà pour être très
honnête avec vous ce matin on a parlé
avec
la société qui organise le déplacement
d'un train de voir si on ne peut pas se
dépasser en char à voile
un char à voile pour charrier christophe
galtier avant le match contre la
juventus au parc des princes greenpeace
est venue manifester sa colère
les torquemada les tartuffes les
robespierre qui tombe ce matin à bras
raccourcis sur christophe galtier
illustre qu'on ne badine pas avec la
nouvelle religion qu'est l'écologie char
à voile est un blasphème galthie un
hérétique et mbappé un renégat aller
chercher querelle au psg parce que des
gens voyagent en avion n'a pas beaucoup
de sens la polémique est ridicule comme
tant de sujets que la pensée unique pose
sur la table
le droit
c'est la voix tout cas je ne m'en excuse
mais pas dans leur château là où il sans
fil pendant qu'on va nous on est six
autres nous on est de droit dont l'essai
nous on porte des mocassins à glands les
droits que l'on laissé
mon pays commence à me faire peur en
fait non mais je plaisante pas mon fils
commence à me faire peur alors moi je
supporte supporters du rc lens j'aime
pas le psg j'ai même bien quand le psg
perd oui mais lâche objets défendre
galtier mbappé quoi mais c'est quoi ce
pays on peut faire une blague c'est à
dire que le sujet de l'écologie s'est
alarmé c'est devenu le totem absolue la
nouvelle religion on peut même plus
faire de blagues sur l'environnement et
la sempa sur l'environnement sur le
déplacement moi je la trouve pas mauvais
je trouve très bonne cette blague
l'entraîneur du paris saint germain a
fait une pirouette on va se déplacer en
char à voile les grands prêtres sont
sortis de leur église de leur grotte de
leurs gonds pour fustiger cette ironie
mal placé il éructe l'anathème on ne
rigole pas avec le co2 galtier a répondu
comme un mousquetaire du roi comme un
esprit libre al'inverse des petits
hommes gris qui sature l'espace
médiatique chez dumas galtier ce raid
d'artagnan chéreau ce temps il serait
cyrano
[Applaudissements]
on n'a jamais ministère
elles sont brûlants le maire
lui deuxième image que je voulais vous
proposez voilà comment arrivera le paris
saint germain lors d'un prochain match
de championnat
[Musique]
et donc les joueurs seront indirectement
comme ça sur la pelouse
[Musique]
jdo
george jackson n'est jamais à sec
descendre un réservoir inutilisés ride
et une piscine abandonné
face au réchauffement climatique
on discute ni les goûts ni les couleurs